bis jetzt 20 größten funktionen aber ich
muss sagen man kann es auf jeden fall
messen
[Musik]
hey was geht ab und herzlich willkommen
bei einem neuen video also auf jeden
fall laufen funktioniert was das hier
eigentlich noch mal ich glaube das
brauche ich mal für einen video auf
jeden fall für mich geht es jetzt zu
meinen eltern
es geht allerdings auch um eine neue 24
stunden challenge und diesmal wirklich
umfasst kasse ist wir haben jetzt 21 uhr
1 also 21 41 mal mit was wirklich
außergewöhnlichen ich habe es sehr sehr
sehr sehr oft in den kommentaren gelesen
und zwar macht doch mal 24 stunden rot
schwarz grün blau ihr fragt euch jetzt
wahrscheinlich navi rot blau grün war
ist und zwar wollte ich erst mal etwas
einfach am anfang wir machen heute 24
stunden nur rote produkte also ich weiß
nun auch nach hause holen im kleinen
snack morgen dann wie immer frühstück
mittagessen abendessen komplett rot ist
ja auch komisch an
sinnvoller wäre ja würde ich 24 stunden
orange machen wenn man sich so meinen
pulli anschaut aber das machen wir
vielleicht beim nächsten mal
ihr könnt ja mal eure lieblings farbe in
die kommentare schreiben dann gibt es
beim nächsten mal einfach die farbe die
haben meist in den kommentaren steht und
das mir sehr gerne und dann nach oben
dafür weitere preis ganz ganz wichtig
daumen nach oben
außerdem war ich werd autowasch echt
wieder aus wie neu schwarz wir auch eine
interessante frage das wollte ich
eigentlich erst machen das
sollte kurz vor der autobahnauffahrt ist
hier eine tankstelle sondern größere und
da habe ich jetzt gerade in sachen
gefunden dafür schon so schön besser und
zweimal zum trinken powerade habe ich
schon ewig nicht mehr getrunken ich
wusste gar nicht dass das auch wirklich
in roth gibt und ein paar gummibärchen
aber wie gesagt ist er ein kleiner snack
als lustige war ich musste mir karte
zahlen weil ich hatte kein bargeld mehr
das geht allerdings erst bei 5 euro ja
und jetzt habe ich mir noch diese
kaugummis cool ich muss mal gucken ob
die wirklich gut sind
ansonsten ein problem sollte einen
wunderschönen guten morgen habe ich mal
kurz zum tor
dieses zimmer also ich würde es
irgendwie immer noch geil so weil es in
dem kinder zumeist aber es ist halt
wirklich hässlich und erfolge stellt
hier passt irgendwie gar nichts zusammen
hier steht noch so ein wisch auto-fan
bett mit ihrem micky maus jeder sofa
schreibtisch ach so walter das war ja
mal so geil und hier drehte ab und zu
mal ein video leute ich glaube ich
glaube ich habe gestern gar nicht mehr
aufgenommen bei diesem getränk kommen so
erinnerungen hoch ich habe das bestimmt
schon acht jahre nicht mehr getrunken
früher immer so auf geburtstagen gab es
ist immer in der soccer an also wenn ein
kindergeburtstag war und man fußball
gespielt zur soccerhalle kennt ja
wahrscheinlich habe ich immer das
genommen in blau
das schmeckt so ähnlich bisschen mehr
nach und die habe ich auch noch zu
finden keine story zu erzählen aber ich
früher auch sehr gerne gegessen und
irgendwann habe ich dann schon mal zu
viel gegessen und da waren wir so
schlecht dass ich mich übergeben musste
heute wegen jetzt einkaufen frühstück
mittagessen und dann schauen wir heute
formal nicht aus meinem ausfall so ich
schon gesagt es geht ja um
ausschließlich um rote produkte deswegen
bin ich jetzt wirklich mal gespannt was
ist so zum frühstück gibt
ich bin wieder da irgendwie bin ich
erfolg ist rum geehrt und wusste gar
nicht so wohl suchst du es überhaupt
hätte ich mich vorher mal ein bisschen
darüber informieren sollen auf jeden
fall habe ich zumindest ein frühstück
zusammen gefunden
die verkäuferin dachte sich
wahrscheinlich auch so ist der typ dumm
oder warum kauft ja alles in rot
okay leute noch ein kleines update ich
habe mich jetzt gerade rote produkte
weiter informiert und ich bin irgendwie
nicht ganz zufrieden mit dem was ich
gekauft habe deswegen fahren wir jetzt
noch zu einem anderen supermarkt ja noch
größer ist als dieser sofort markant ist
und einfach bei lidl versuchen das liebe
logo hier trotzdem brauche ich jetzt
irgendwas zu essen
ich habe hunger moment mal das ja was zu
trinken
im internet steht immer was von roten
nudeln
irgendwie finde ich die nirgendwo gibt
es so leute supermarkt nummer 3 also
dass auf jeden fall der größte hier
deswegen ich gebe mein bestes leute
leider gibt es auch hier anscheinend
keine roten nudeln sofort leider keine
roten auch also leute das sollte
eigentlich reichen für 24 stunden das
hier finde ich auch ganz interessant
kann man finde ich als rot durchgehen
lassen wer mir so barbecue roth das weiß
ich und hier war ich mir auch unsicher
habe ich auch noch nie probiert diese
tomaten und italienische kräuter
für mich ist das eigentlich gut was
besseres gibt okay heute endlich wieder
zu hause habe ich schon unterwegs ist
jetzt machen wir uns hier mal ein
leckeres frühstück
[Musik]
also ich habe wirklich mein bestes
gegeben
irgendwie ist das nicht rot sondern eher
lila bedeutet du mir wirklich leid wenn
davon aus sagen das ist schön knallig
rot habe ich willst du wenn das so
vorgestellt naja immerhin haben wir dann
getränk das rot ist dass es kirschsaft
na ja wenn es eigentlich schon fast
mittagszeit deswegen ich habe hunger
und ich frage mich gerade warum ich
nicht einfach richtig roten gekauft hab
es gibt so oder so leute war auf jeden
fall ganz lecker das bedeutet ist echt
schlecht leute wählst du
das frühstück war jetzt nicht allzu viel
deswegen habe ich mir gedacht machen wir
direkt weiter mit dem mittagsmenü und
zwar habe ich euch ja schon erklärt ich
konnte keine rothenuffeln finden ja also
ich habe die menschen halt gefunden dass
es sowas wird natürlich gerne einbinden
dann wenn ich aber weiterlaufen rezept
gestoßen man das selber machen kann und
in liefern das klappt probieren wir
heute mal ist auch relativ easy kann ich
euch auch gerne mal ein werden hier also
spart das ist einfach mal nach und und
probleme das ganze sachen habe ich alles
eingekauft ich hoffe es wird rot
[Musik]
okay ich bin fertig und ich bin
eigentlich soweit zufrieden also ist auf
jeden fall deutlich rot dann habe ich
gestern doch dieses getränk gekauft
blutorange ist allerdings nicht sofort
wieder kirschsaft trotzdem lasse ich das
auch mal als rot durchgehen oder und so
sieht dann das mittagessen aus jetzt bin
ich mal gespannt ist jetzt waren es die
größere portion aber ich muss sagen man
kann es auf jeden fall gut essen
auch der saft hier wirklich sehr gesund
der nährstoff halt ich kann man nur
empfehlen
zurück im auto ich fahre jetzt noch
meinen großeltern besuchen und habe mir
gedacht
wir schauen ob noch was rotes finden
also banken müsste ich auch noch bis
gleichzeitig eine sehr gute idee
sollte nämlich demnächst mal wieder ein
video machen wo ich so neue fast food
produkte testen ich habe eine werbung
gesehen ich bin noch ein bisschen und
ich habe ich das nicht schon mal
probiert haben aber werde ich gleich
merken also wir sehen uns gleich hallo
ich hätte gerne einmal diesen roten
smoothie diesen rothens musiker mit
kirsche oder so genau
danke
leider auf jeden fall hammer wetter ich
musste noch franken
kennt ihr diese kommunikativen menschen
die man eigentlich gar nicht kennt die
aber trotzdem nach intensiven gesprächen
schöne grüße auf jeden fall habe ich mir
jetzt im dieses getränke geholt ich bin
mir unsicher das ist die monarchie
limette kirsche genau lag auf dem weg
deswegen bin ich mal gespannt
ich bin eigentlich ganz neues und das
erfrischt also bei warmen temperaturen
so wie wir sie heute haben oder gar
einen kofferraum ist offen ist das ein
kleines getränk trage ich mich frage
warum ist der kofferraum auf das revier
noch total der sache muss ich mal kurz
auf den grund gehen
doch nicht mit sondersitzung auch keiner
drin hier könnt ihr das sehen also wenn
jemand ein auto worauf ihr steht 1 leute
was wir da ja das was vorgestellt ist
auch ganz entspannt
das abendessen das ding ist nämlich wir
haben noch besuch und ich habe das jetzt
gerade ich muss mich also ich muss mich
wirklich beiden und ich hab mir das
jetzt alle noch gekocht hier einmal eine
tomatensuppe die ich früher ich gerne
gegessen habe im schönen roth ich weiß
nicht vielleicht sieht es war jetzt
nicht so gut aus wie es eigentlich ist
worüber ich mich ein bisschen auftrag
ist noch diese dinger ja ja vielleicht
bin ich auch mal wieder dumm und das ist
mit aufstrich oder so aber ich denke
nicht dass ich absolut keine ähnlichen
ja wenn ich das fertig habe dann war es
auf jeden fall ein sehr sehr guter tag
für mich kennen sich ja wahrscheinlich
die weiblichen zuschauer auch mit auch
muss ich mir überlegen ob ich das mit
rein schneide ich früher mal unglaublich
gerne brot in die tomatensoße betont das
machen wir jetzt mal hier mit
[Musik]
nein ich glaube mein problem ist leute
wie war das nochmal
naja ich bin nicht dumm kirche hier
nicht sogar draußen ab wie ist das denn
jetzt passiert wollen das eigentlich
auch meinen lieblingspullover der stadt
jetzt in ruhe auch wenn mein vater aber
schon weil die letzte mahlzeit hier
alter und es wird auf jeden fall wieder
gut leute lasst euch nicht von dem sturm
hier behörden
ich wollte nur noch entspannt das fazit
aufnimmt zum video weil es ja und man
ganz wichtig muss mich allerdings auch
über einen goldgehalt wie gesagt einen
besuch haben die denken sich
wahrscheinlich macht macht er da oben
brot ist erst mit 24 stunden wie kann
man denn so sein geld von ihren
unglaublichen spaß also ich muss
wirklich sagen es war sehr interessant
und das hat mir spaß gemacht also ist
man will spaß gemacht die challenge also
für mich in der hinsicht weil ich in so
kurzer zeit wieder so viel neues
ausprobiere was man sonst niemals
ausprobieren würde deswegen ist mir sehr
wichtig dass ihr jetzt eure lieblings
haben meint wegelin kommentare schreibt
oder die farbe mit der ich das mal
machen soll
und dann gibt's demnächst nämlich den
nächsten part ich kann nur sagen ich
hoffe es hat euch gefallen lasse mir
sehr gerne haben nach oben da und wir
machen diese essens videos in der zelle
extrem viel spaß
ich würde mich auch vielleicht so ein
bisschen was kochen angeht mehr
engagieren dass ich da halt einen
besseren plan von habe und selber sachen
kreieren kann sagen was man so tegtmeier
instagram ab da er sich einfach alex wie
und wo ich noch irgendwas sagen ach so
angaben zum preis und zu den kalorien
die ich gegessen wie ich jetzt in den
letzten tagen schon videos gemacht habe
mache ich heute nicht weil ich erstens
über 30 euro sachen eingekauft habe die
alle roth warnt ich jetzt einmal gut da
draußen völlig in der zeit aber nur
höchstens ein drittel genutzt
deswegen kann man sagen ungefähr zehn
euro vielleicht ein bisschen mehr
einfach weil es jetzt nichts gibt was
halt rot ist wo ich dann wirklich
komplett richtig satt davon also ich
gehe auf jeden fall später noch was
essen aber das ist den challenger schon
vorbei das was mir haut rein und wir
sehen uns ja